foreign
that's why paganism and politicism and
disbelief and Atheism is forbidden Islam
okay Islam can't preserve the intellect
that's why drugs and alcohol is
forbidden
but the Islam came to preserve wealth
that's what interest and gambling is
forbidden
fourth Islam came to preserve lineage
and marriage and and the families that's
what for fornication adultery is
forbidden last Islam came to preserve
life
that's what can you solve for killing
people unjustly or how many your body is
forbidden so this fact Islam came to
preserve and guess what and gets the
most disaster things which is alcohol
gambling interest and fornication and it
goes back to us
instead so the question ask yourself
firstly there's no any doubt there some
people are benefiting from these vices
from alcohol gambling interesting
establishments those who are in power so
that's why maturity of science those are
very statistics that are those who are
making money for the people
that's why what they do they utilize
their wealth to make Islam look bad even
though Islam is good for us individuals
and how they're doing it now they're
doing it through education and social
media but we know God is all powerful
but Islam is the fast growing origin in
the face of success
[Music]
in Europe
the chance is declining
Christianity when the churches are empty
you know many Europeans use
young people left Christianity
in Europe in a country when there's many
doubts against Islam but people live
this life which many people in our
country desires but people left it and
accept Islam because the true Freedom
will become a servant of your Creator
and the truth of the evil slavery when
you become a slave of your desires and
Society more difficult has said does it
make sense
yeah let me ask this question you might
just say to you bro please I'll be
speaking to you for long I will give you
two million pounds as a gift
what would you say to me at least but if
you do take it beautiful too many pounds
yeah
I'm a billionaire just take it as a gift
what would you say to me
would you remember me all the time
of course
if I'm a billionaire and you don't have
no money I'll give you two million
pounds as a gift what would you say no
but if you do take that gift from me
what would you say to me
and you remember me all the time of
course too many parties are big money
bro I will give you two million pounds
by the way on the condition Give Me Your
Eyes
you say no why because your eyes is more
valuable than 2 million pounds so why
not grateful and remember who gave ice
for free
make sense you see now you want to be
grateful to him you want to worship him
now let me ask this question if you want
to buy a gift for your mother would you
buy a gift that your love or your mother
love
likewise it will be grateful to create
you want to worship him you should be
grateful to him the way he loves that's
why he said Jesus before that Moses
Abraham now the last of them is the
Prophet Muhammad
Christianity is dying today's is dying
nowadays a war against human nature you
know the inner you know now people now
they believe even they haven't been they
believe the animals you know about this
transgender you know it you know let me
give you an example imagine What's Your
Name by the way sorry
huh
yeah
I said Jose I believe I was born in the
wrong body I believe I was born in the
wrong body I should have been armless
even though you please see would you
help me to come from us
[Music]
my arm is okay yeah yeah but I believe I
should I should have no arms
[Music]
but I'm having myself
help me okay if someone's gonna kill
himself and he said I'm gonna kill
myself but I'm gonna give you money to
kill me I'm gonna kill him no no because
he's gonna do it no no I wouldn't help
him because um
I actually had a harm me or you're gonna
say no no see wait don't harm yourself
above your arm is healthy
in the hospital
and there's nothing wrong with the arm
um
I'll just tell them this and that he
knows how I live with our um things like
that things like that like they say
yeah I hear it but I'm gonna still cut
up my arm I'll tell them
your life
but you want to help him to cut it off
no I wouldn't help that is my friends of
course you cannot control him of course
you're gonna advise him it's my point
yeah but you're not gonna help him
because he feels he's harmless even
though clearly you can see um I'm not
gonna happen my point here is what no
man really is a man because he feels he
he should be he's on the wrong body he's
a woman what we're doing we happen into
everything off and this is what is
happening now there's a war against
human nature and the only religion that
I stand and said I guess these evil
people want to destroy us is Islam you
understand that's why you know about
educate yeah
he's been oppressed these people oppress
him yes he said things which is wrong
all of us will make mistakes no doubt
but when he became Muslim because he
said I'm a multi-millionaire as he kept
the point when I met people who worship
Satan associated with my own eyes and
the only religion that is Take Me First
and guess them is Islam and because the
operations from the almighty even there
is the people that the people that fight
against Islam from the world point of
view from Material point of view they
have a strong weapons but yeah
spreading you understand so that's what
I'm saying that's why there's
overwhelming proves what Islam is the
truth and like I said if I saved your
life or I'll give you too many if I'll
give you two million pounds you'll
remember me all the time you have God
gave your life for free everything so
why are you wasting your time to accept
Islam and worship God the Lord step by
step only because somebody has to be
perfect all of us
but you become Muslim
s
that there's no one word
of worship except Allah
understand just step by step you have a
Muslim start learning fasting that's
good but when you first knock is that
you're not gonna get reward but only
fast as a Muslim you get a reward and
remember this stuff is a test how many
people left the house they never come
back how many people would sleep I'm
gonna wake up in the morning go take
their lives are we ready to meet God and
there's the greatest evil against God is
when you turn away from him especially
when the truth was clarified to you and
you accept it but you turn away from it
that is a big evil understand it so you
should become Muslim you make sense to
you it won't be late
sorry
movies yeah
it's the truth
is
Jesus it doesn't make any sense
have
people yeah but again
it's about faith but the effect is it
based upon God's teaching or based upon
Constitution
for our desires that's what that's why
it shows people amongst us Jesus is one
of them Moses Abraham Noah
all of them came to teach us how to
worship God in the same room that's what
I'm saying so what I would say to you
that when it comes to Christianity also
about obey your parents it's good to
obey your parents but there's priorities
God be for your parents Abraham he's far
away with he was a vegan and he never
obeyed his father by becoming a pagan
he's not worshiping the true God you
understand so respective parents even
though and teach us even if your parents
are not a Muslim still be good to them
you understand however when you die
they'll pray inside the grave and they
will leave you so we're gonna meet you
create up and your first one will help
you you understand that's why what I
showed you look I'm showing you the
proof that there's there's no huge
unders Christianity bro because
Christianity is about being cherished
that's it Islam is about being in a
mosque outside islamically implemented
not just for you also for the government
that's why because system free you from
this type of following desires becoming
worse than animal and the people are
making money from that they don't like
it with this Islam teaching the opposite
what they want that's what the original
understand even though the Muslims are
weak the Muslim countries in terms of
material point of view yet Islam is
spreading and Allah mentioned in the
Quran 1 400 years ago the allowment is
then spread
bro logical rational you understand
for so many years
you have a library now
hey where are you from don't go lost
we are every Friday
if you have questions inshallah maybe we
come with him before Ramadan
every Friday
we've been here for the last 10 years
here
every Friday weekend Friday
where are you from
how's the music yeah yeah what about you
and we have our Instagram page here